I've been testing Korean skincare products I've
seen recommended again and again by influencers
I couldn't fit them all into
one video so here is part two
it's Michelle of lab muffin beauty
science chemistry PhD and cosmetic chemist
Korean skincare products are super popular
but there are so many options
it can be really overwhelming
how do you work out which products to buy?
ingredient lists are helpful but
any cosmetic chemist will tell
you you can't judge how well
a product works just from that
every chocolate cake has pretty
much the same ingredients but this
one tastes like broken dreams and disappointment
the ingredient list can give you an
idea of what to expect if you know what
you're looking for but it doesn't
replace testing it on actual skin
so I always check reviews on forums
but also from influencers I trust
especially if they have similar skin to mine today
I'll be adding my thoughts on
these products and hopefully
give you some useful ingredient insights as well
these products are all available from this video's
sponsor stylekorean there's a
discount code in the caption too
I'm going to start with the Skinfood
Royal Honey Propolis Enrich Essence
this is a long time favorite in the Korean
skincare community it's been recommended
by so many people Kelly Driscoll James
Welsh Liah Yoo Bonnie Garner Ben Neely
I was initially a bit iffy about
an active product from Skinfood
I've loved their pineapple peeling gel
for a long time but a lot of skinfood
products seem kind of gimmicky
with this food and natural theme
as someone who got into skincare in the
Pinterest age I have a bit of a reaction to that
this is the first active product I've tried
from Skinfood it's pretty multifunctional
it's made for hydrating and supporting
the skin barrier but it's also meant
to help with breakouts as well as plump
and firm skin so targeting "mature skin"
the key ingredient is black bee propolis
extract propolis is bee glue it's used to
seal up holes in hives it's made from plant
sap and it has some interesting properties
it's been investigated for use in wounds in skin
care it seems to be good for soothing helping
with breakouts and as a source of antioxidants
specifically it has polyphenols and flavonoids
skinfood's propolis is double fermented to make
it more concentrated there are two other bee
ingredients in this there's royal jelly which has
skin smoothing properties and fermented aged honey
all of these are natural ingredients
so the specific substances in them
and their concentrations depend on lots
of different factors the species of bee
what they eat the season how
it's extracted and processed
so for these sorts of ingredients i always
recommend looking at reviews of specific
products and ignoring things like dupes
and percentages that's not super helpful
i found this essence incredibly hydrating
which is exactly what i expected
as well as the bee extracts which all have
really hydrating components there's also
beta glucan this is a long chain sugary
molecule that's really good at holding
onto water and acting as a humectant
it's similar to hyaluronic acid there
is also hyaluronic acid and glycerin which are
both also humectants holding water onto skin
it also has purslane extract i am not
even going to try to pronounce that i
can do chemistry names but botanical names
that is a skill tree i have not filled out
this is a herb that's used in traditional
korean medicine to help with irritated skin
there are also some ferments which can have
hydrating soothing and exfoliating effects
these were added into this newer
enriched version along with more propolis
excitingly for people who can't handle
niacinamide this does not have niacinamide
it's a bit of an older product that was
released before that big niacinamide boom
it's also fragrance free and
has a slightly sweet smell
people with sensitive skin have generally
said that their skin doesn't react to this
in terms of texture this is silky and
hydrating it's like a thick sort of
water not as thin as a toner but not as
thick as a proper serum it sinks into my
skin really quickly and it isn't as tacky as
i expected for something that hydrates so well
the most impressive effect i've seen
on my skin with this is that it's been
really good at smoothing out texture and
giving me a glow overnight it's almost
like a chemical exfoliant sort of effect
but without any irritation or stinging
it was also really good at calming
down reddish breakouts i had
it layers nicely under products too i'm
actually wearing it under my makeup right
now but i think it would be a bit sticky
for daytime wear if it's really humid
i really like the packaging of this
too it's a glass bottle with this
gradient effect and it's heavy enough at the
bottom that i haven't knocked it over yet
there is also this nice button on top
that you press to fill up the dropper
it's summer here and i've been using this on its
own as my only product at night including when
I've got the aircon on and it's been really
good at preventing my skin from drying out
I'm sure I'll have to add a moisturizer
too when it gets colder and drier
overall I love this it is going into my rotation
Skin1004 Madagascar centella light
cleansing oil is one of Skin1004's
most popular products Soo Beauty
and Euniunni both raved about this
cleansing oils and balms are really popular
in Korean skin care you don't need to use an
oil-based cleanser to remove water resistant
makeup and sunscreen but I prefer using them
because it feels so relaxing to massage
it into my skin and see everything mess up
sometimes I like mess
a lot of cleansing oils and balms leave a bit of
residue on your skin and might not get all of your
makeup off so you often need to follow up with
a second cleanser also called double cleansing
this cleansing oil is designed to work
well on its own and when I tested it
on some water resistant products I
didn't need to use a second cleanser
this has centella in it which is
good for soothing skin and people
have tried this on irritated skin
have said that it's quite calming
this also worked really well for
removing waterproof eyeliner it
didn't sting my eyes or leave them blurry
which sometimes happens with cleansing
oils and that blurriness is almost
always an issue with cleansing balms
I really like this pump bottle the pump actually
dispenses the right amount of product really
easily lately I've been trying a few products that
don't dispense well out of their pumps the product
will just kind of leap over my hand onto the floor
so I have been really appreciating this aspect
the things I don't really like about this product
are really just personal preference things for me
I don't really like the scent it's kind of
lemony and citrus it comes from
bergamot rose and rose geranium
I also just prefer cleansing balms over
cleansing oils because I find these a bit
tricky to get onto my face without dripping
I really don't like cleaning up oil drips
if you're looking for a cleansing oil especially
one that you can use on your eyes or one that
doesn't need to be followed up with a second
cleanser then I think this is a fantastic option
next is the Jumiso all-day vitamin brightening
and balancing serum I've seen this recommended
by tons of people including Cassandra bankson
Tina Tanaka Harris Euniunni and Meejmuse
this is a serum that's based around
seabuckthorn fruit extract which
they use as like the water source for this product
they call it vitamin tree because
it contains a lot of vitamins mainly
vitamin C but also E and K it also has a
lot of antioxidant and humectant compounds
on top of that this serum has added humectants
like glycerin and hyaluronic acid 2% niacinamide
some other beneficial plant extracts
panthenol and additional ascorbic acid
I found that this was really hydrating
and lightweight it sinks in quickly and
layers nicely under sunscreen and makeup
it didn't irritate my skin at all and it
has a nice light citrus scent with
none of that metallic kind of smell
you usually get with ascorbic acid products
but I didn't notice any of the beneficial
effects I usually see with vitamin C
like faster brightening of acne marks
I think here's where I went wrong I didn't
check the brand's own recommendations this
is their beginner vitamin C they have
two stronger options which probably
would have been more suitable for me as
someone whose skin really likes vitamin C
A lot of people do have issues with vitamin C in
the form of ascorbic acid in their products these
products can be really irritating and cause
breakouts especially if they have a low pH
that low pH isn't always necessary for ascorbic
acid to get into skin and work there are other
ways to get it into skin even with water-based
products so this serum might be good for you if
your skin is super sensitive to vitamin C you want
something budget friendly and you're okay if it is
mostly just hydrating with any vitamin C action
as an added bonus but if your budget stretches
a bit more and you're specifically looking for
a vitamin C product I would recommend looking
for a product that has more ascorbic
acid but is still formulated to be gentle
next is the pyunkang yul
calming moisture repair balm
I love it I'm sorry for that spoiler
I can't hold back this is just awesome
I talked about pyunkang yul last time they're
a brand that uses a lot of traditional Korean
medicinal ingredients they're one
of gothamista's favorite brands
and the essence toner was nice but it
didn't fit into my routine that well
I don't see many people talking
about this bomb except Soo Beauty
and Tina Tanaka Harris maybe it gets lost
amongst all of pky's other moisturizers
they also have a cream in a jar that looks
pretty much the same with a very similar
name that costs less for more product so I
think maybe people tend to just skip over this
I tried this by chance and I am so
glad I did so my usual product for
when my skin's irritated is the la roche-posay
cicaplast baume B5 I've talked about it a lot
when I went to Europe I knew I would be buying
the new B5 plus so I put this in my hand luggage
instead to help with dry skin on the plane I
mostly just put it in there because it is so
small and I didn't really expect that much
from it it was just meant to tide me over
this is brilliant as you'd expect it has a lot of
the standard soothing barrier support actives like
panthenol and centella there's also honeysuckle
and tea tree extracts but no niacinamide
it also works really well for softening those
stiff dry flakes that I tend to get
when I've blown my nose too much
the magic with this product is the texture the big
issue with the cicaplast baume is that the texture
is just not great it's thick and paste like and
that is fine at night but if you try to wear it
during the day especially with sunscreen or makeup
then it becomes a bit of a greasy slidy mess
this calming moisture repair balm has a thickish
texture and I expected it to be a bit gooey and
sticky like a lip balm but this just glides on
so smoothly and sinks into skin really quickly
a little does go a long way with this and you can
apply a really thin even layer without any tugging
I've also used a thicker layer overnight when it
felt like my whole face just
needed that extra nurturing
it is heavier than most Korean moisturizers
which tend to be super lightweight but compared
to even a western moisturizer for oily skin
this is just so weightless and refreshing
but even though it's light it still feels
like you have a protective layer on your
skin or like a layer that's merged with
the top layers of your skin it isn't greasy
or oily or slidey and it actually has a
matte finish if you don't apply too much
it almost feels like a silicone-based
moisturizer but it actually doesn't have
silicones in it it has a lot of lightweight
emollients like squalane and sunflower oil
and there's also shea butter there are
also lots of humectants in it that keep
water on your skin like glycerin betaine and
a bunch of different sizes of hyaluronic acid
having those different sizes I found tends to
be more effective for giving
me longer lasting hydration
there are also these two peptides in it which can
smooth and firm skin but I didn't really see that
happening when I was using it because I was too
busy focusing on my skin not falling off my face
I haven't tried this much in cold dry weather
yet so it'll be interesting to see if my skin
does need a second moisturizer but so far
this has been an absolute dream product
I hope you enjoyed chatting skincare with me
you might also like this video on sunscreens
let me know what you thought about these products
hit the like and the subscribe and comment to tell
the algorithm to give you more of this kind of
video and in the meantime happy skincare nerding